tonight on Kitchen Nightmares Chef
Ramsay heads to music City Nashville
Tennessee but he is immediately forced
to deal with a sour note what the hell
are you doing this Cajun restaurant is
run by Chef owner champion
whose careless methods have hurt his
Eatery they hate it all as well as his
wife's confidence show that you care oh
we have done all of this for nothing he
blames Nashville customers yeah both
came back that's the Nashville folks we
know and love when he should really be
taking a hard look oh my God that is
less than appetizing food it looks like
chappie took a crappie in my gumbo and
his disturbing kitchen practices you see
them all in these things and in spite of
Chef Ramsay showing him the way you have
to open your eyes chappie prefers his
own destructive route you don't know
what the hell you're talking about this
place should be shut down find out if
Chef Ramsay can get through to the
stubborn owner listen to me something
not regular doing there's nothing wrong
with or will chappies come Crashing Down
[Music]
what is that you serve me rotten Cruise
thank yourself
Nashville Tennessee the epicenter of
country music and home to Chappy's
Restaurant a Cajun Eatery owned by John
chappie Chapman and his wife Starr
they're pretty I started when I was
about two and a half with my mother in
the kitchen I was the one that would put
the crabs in the pot
thank you for coming we opened our first
tappies in a little town called Long
Beach Mississippi in 1984. Bon Appetit
and it was a huge overnight success
but in 2005 after Hurricane Katrina
destroyed the restaurant champion star
were forced to relocate to Nashville
doesn't like the crab cakes or the
turtles too and the Nashville folks we
know and love I think people in
Nashville have a problem with New
Orleans Cuisine they hate it all
oh well these people don't know
fun
I definitely don't think our issue is
the people of Nashville
the issue is more chappy don't argue
move on heavy is extremely hard-headed
there's nothing wrong with my food yeah
both came back
if chappie would listen to feedback the
business would be doing much better
it's a barrel Mundy that's what I need
working the menu It's like a book I do
want to let you know about some
appetizers that we're featuring tonight
that are not listed not to mention the
15 16 things we have to recite we have
crab cakes in here swordfish Piccata we
also have our blackened shrimp two
lobster tails that's stacked on top of
one another twice I think that's it I
said etchupe right I can't see how he he
makes any money we do not have the
volume to be able to sell all that stuff
chapies definitely needs an update it's
not 1984 anymore they called they want
their wallpaper back
[Music]
chappie on 120 the lady did not like the
salad dress what's the matter with it
she said the blue cheese dressing is too
thin just get her out of here yes chappy
everybody thinks they know better so
it's my job to make sure it stays the
way it's supposed to be what are y'all
doing I need to know we're taking the
prime rib off of his check because he
didn't like it and he returned he didn't
like the other one either he sent them
both back the fish too for chappies to
be saved I think we need chubby to
change why waste my time
and it's not about your pride or your
experience it's about doing what you
need to do to help your business evolve
and go to the next level I don't know
what's happening ultimately the success
of chappies relies on champion
[Music]
oh geez wow what is that
ghostly hello hi welcome wow what
Adventures that was that mannequin is
[__] scary no jeez
oh spooked me now first name is I'm
Nicole nice to see you wow this place is
like a museum in here yes got a lot of
uh New Orleans paraphernalia everywhere
chappie and star actually his wife had a
restaurant on the Gulf Coast
wow wow wow is that in there where the
big chef's hat that is yes wow where is
the man uh he is actually in the kitchen
I'd like to have a quick word with him
sure let me go check thank you I'll be
right back
oh wow what's that it looks like a
costume that Elton John would wear is
that chappie wow
Chef Ramsay just got here and before he
sits he wants to know if you have a
second to chat with him it'll be just a
few minutes okay
he's gonna be right out yeah excellence
[Music]
yeah he's going to be right out he told
me
[Music]
is he alone in the kitchen does he have
any assistance no he's he's got some
back there he's uh I think there's three
men back there with him wow let me go
check and see how he's doing okay
excellent
thank you
are we getting close chappie yeah okay
he is right up in the front
[Music]
I only get a glass of water then I'll go
meet Darth Vader
wow how are you Gordon nice to meet you
those pants are my pepper brother wow
wow wow so back to the 80s it's just
something I've always worn wow look at
that thing there that's when I was cute
and young cute and young how long do you
remember those days I do but just take
me back to the beginning how long have
you been here since uh June of oh six
right after Katrina what's the
comparison between here and Mississippi
Mississippi was kind of a never-ending
because like 23 years so it was a long
time and successful business and doing
what I do you're amazing and here it
took me through the first two years
business-wise kind of a rough uh
beginning here in Nashville of course we
were the new guys in town people are
afraid of us you know we don't do
traditional Nashville Food burgers and
pulled pork and chicken wings we don't
do that so we we do to New Orleans food
so a lot of people were afraid and
that's what we're trying to deal with
still to this day and here you're taking
a play on fine dining oops it's it more
like I'm taking a play on casual fine
time yeah but I mean look at those
napkins yeah um weight is bow ties I
mean it doesn't strike me as somewhere
casual I mean it's quite informal huh
no right okay my dad I've been doing
this a long time I've eaten all over the
world I see what people do I don't think
I'm so far off and how would you rate
your food currently out of 10 would you
give it I would put it out of I didn't
think it was delicious just asking I
give them a 10 every time I do it you
know okay well let me sit down have a
little around the menu and uh get up to
speed with your your style of cookie
okay thank you I think they have a table
over there for you yes I think my food
is the best New Orleans cuisine in
Nashville hands down so I can't figure
out why people haven't come enjoy
all right I was gonna put my chappie
well we actually get a lot of people to
do that
little chapies okay so this is our Lunch
selection right here wow something lunch
menu yeah dinner menu is even larger
thank you absolutely
wow
hello how are you fantastic and yourself
I'm so happy to be here welcome to
chappies my name is TJ TJ we have like
10 different specials what as well as
five different appetizers
15 specials yes
on top of this yeah and they change
every day it's a lot to take in no eggs
actually has stayed exactly the same
they've been the same since I've been
here wow so you know this um 895
crawfish I saw it's on there twice it's
the same on the lunch menu as it is on
the dinner menu only the price changes
so for lunch menu the core fish to two
Bay is 8.95 how much is it for dinner on
the special uh 29.95 so it jumps 20 and
what changes
nothing
EJ come on
the price jumps three and a half times
for the special of the dinner and
nothing changes you don't even throw me
an extra couple of towels in there
shame on you TJ well not me is that just
for the
crawfish or is that all the specials
pretty much it's pretty standard wow
so let's start off with fleas in the
fine green tomatoes please okay the
chicken and sausage gumbo as well please
okay and I gotta go for that steak and
lobster rocket very good
thank you
wow Fried Green Tomatoes thank you
fried green
the rest of his order is going in now
[Music]
hello oh hello how are you I'm Ravi how
are you nice to meet you star Chapman
star nice to see you please take a seat
well welcome um thank you I'm happy to
be here my first time in Nashville
really how do you like it yeah wonderful
thank you
how about you are you involved with
business lady always yes Hands-On I walk
the front of the house I work the office
wow I wear many hats I have to your
husband of course Chaffee um how long
you been together 29 years 29 years yes
sir does he listen to your input not
always not always why because he's a
hard-headed man I think he's uh said in
his ways but it's not working due to
dabs exactly looking at our menu I think
it's too big I think it needs to be
downsized it's too much you've got to be
able to adapt and change it seems like
you've hit a wall
absolutely and that's why you're here
I think that's going to be the key I
believe Chef Ramsay is the only person
who could turn chappie around for me
it's like trying to blow air into a
bloom with a hole in it all right the
fried green tomatoes appetizer is that
parmesan on it it is and crawfish tails
and Hollandaise sauce thanks CJ you're
welcome I'm dying to taste these
fragrangements I enjoy thank you well
how would you rate the food by the way
excellent excellent I just think it
needs to be modernized revamped and
the menu
he says it's excellent and yet it needs
to be modernized and revamped that
doesn't sound like excellent because
surely if it was excellent you wouldn't
have to do any of those things
right what do we think of the fried
green tomatoes uh yeah Bland that
Hollandaise sauce is almost just like a
sort of a melted butter yeah it doesn't
even taste of anything sorry about that
not your fault right next up would be
the chicken and sausage gumbo gumbo
thank you for great work
[Music]
you said your Hollandaise sauce was
extremely Bland this tastes like a
strong butter sauce
it's very good
when we bring a dish back to the kitchen
he acts like it's an insult not that
there's possibly something wrong with
the actual dish
number wow it looks like
chappy took a crappie in my gumbo it's
like a puddle it's just watery really
watery
that is [__] disgusting this dish was
done right it could be a game changer
but right now it's a game Ender TJ
there's a problem in the kitchen
it's not even hot it's not hot no I mean
it's just like lukewarm and loopy see
the skin yeah very watery there's no
flavor anywhere just Bland gotcha I'm
gonna fix it I'll bring my next one
thank you okay wow
Champion first of all this is cold it's
just absolutely filled with water filled
with water I thought I drained it very
well
hey hates everything uh-oh you hadn't
liked anything I've done so far
all right garnish it up
steak and lobster Rockets it's like a
lobster rocket
thank you
that's a very funny looking Lobster
seriously how much is this dish
36.95
gee come on stop and why does it feel a
butterfly like that and cut like that
cuts it off and then pounds it thin
he beats the crap out of a fillet
to tenderize it when it's the most
stunning cut wow
[Music]
wow
which one I'll try it no please come on
chewy
the lobster I couldn't even eat
as I was trying to bite down on it it
was bouncing back
steak and lobster rocket someone needs a
[__] rock out of his ass to wake up
oh my God don't swallow that one
do you have napkin
maybe Japanese to get on a [__]
rocket a rocket back to New Orleans to
see how it's properly done fast
he said the dishes just
right down his throat if he doesn't want
it well he couldn't even get through the
state it was all gristle it was gristle
yeah you think gristle bristle and chewy
okay well
it's like butter
is it not Chef Ramsay a dumbass there's
something that I think is absolutely
wrong he doesn't know what he's talking
about I'm gonna tell him you don't know
what the hell you're talking about
after enduring Chappy's flavorless Cajun
cuisine can you take me through the
kitchen please I sure can Chef Ramsay
heads to the kitchen looking for an
explanation I don't know where to stop I
was so excited to come here but I'm
disappointed
uh the five Green Tomatoes what are you
coating them in corn flour cold flour a
little seasoning for me there's no
seasoning there it was Bland
and holiday sauce was just melted butter
yeah
steak in Lobster rocket the lobster was
like rubber
and when you have a 36 entree you don't
expect to see filet pound it
that's the last thing you ever do
I've never met a chef anywhere in the
world that pounds out a filet why would
you pound something that is tender
just the technique of what we do just
shaping so kids stacks it's not clay
it's meat
the chicken and sausage gumbo plant
but you know what forget the seasoning
it wasn't even hot it was a little warm
but I sent it out as soon as I did it so
it was actually bubbling yeah I'm not
exaggerating it wasn't bubbly hot
because I don't find it funny okay
can I have a word on my own with the
owners please you guys get back to
whatever you'd be doing
I'm not going to say this in front of
your staff
you're a joke
food was disgusting everything was off
everything and that's without factoring
in the prices going through each and
every dish
there was a consistent pattern it's like
you've shut shop up and gone home
chappie is not very happy
you're done
are you done
of what just cooking in general
no that's your your best pardon that's
you at your best
kind of
ready
uh I've toned down some spices for
Nashville when we first opened people
complained all right
I'm not looking for excuses well you
know what can I say you asked me to help
but I'm not gonna sit here and blow
smoke up your asses and say food was
amazing
up my whatever so let's not go here and
go through this you've said your piece
let's move on you've given up
given up what
okay I'm gonna get some fresh air me too
do it okay wow
[Music]
time order up uh Mark how does the line
work crack who's flying tonight hurry up
chopping frying tonight okay great
I want to look good
[Music]
all right now we got the first ticket we
got a grill grouper working
chuffy you find the group over the beef
we blackened everything in the same pan
yes what happens if the customer was a
pescetarian a pescatarian yeah they only
eat fish and they don't expect to eat
their fish with meat juices I've never
heard of one okay the truth
wow can't believe that's going out uh
Tom tell me about the table
thank you
chappie we've got two seconds it's one
of your customers really yeah let me
explain something really important
because I'm not [__] around now this
lady is a pescatarian strictly fish I'm
trying to explain because you're not
listening is that her fish was cooked in
there along with the beef it's not a
general practice it's just the things
you never do it's the Golden Rule but
it's totally oblivious do you get sickle
meat oh very easy I'm sorry
I'll make sure that's in a
pan of his own as it should be and cook
properly okay my apologies thank you
and the same stuff that the meat's been
cooked in
oh my God this is disgusting back there
why is oh
where's my nose that color
I thought that was a jar of mustard
what's the day on this
so by 27th of February 2010 expired
three years ago oh my God
what's that
how old is that
raw beef and cooked beef
cannot believe what I'm saying as I
always say everything you need to know
about a chef is in his fridge shrimp
this is done there
absolutely stinking
oh my gosh I love that
what in the [__] is that there's a
shrimp hanging down there that's all
mold unbelievable bloody hell
it's dinner service at Chappy's and Chef
Ramsay has just made a shocking
Discovery oh my God that's all mold
planting how let me be the filthiest
fridge he has ever seen what a mess
this fridge is an absolute mess I have
never seen that ever now I want to know
what the hell are you doing
something that's still something must
have spilled can you stop bullshitting
for once and just try to get real when
are these from just out of Interest
those are fresh potatoes they are fresh
today no they're not fresh today oh my
good gas just touch that what is that
warm have you any idea what happens to
Sauce when it's covered and it's hot
tomorrow morning it's what
sour sour thank you and what is this
from this is a cake that we've this is a
cake we can't even answer me now how old
is that I don't know oh my good glass
see them all in these things yes and
this one here look see that there
you stop you're not getting anything 86
come here you come here now have a look
down there what did you see oh mold you
want me to let you take something else
out of here no no [__] off yes sir have
you any idea how long a shrimp needs to
stay inside the fridge to get that much
mold on there no is it between there is
it between the water I don't know what
it is where it was all night you're just
deflective how about some form of
honesty you need some help obviously he
needs some help are you serious I'm very
serious you are one foot away from those
[__] down there which he obviously
didn't know was down there what what do
you think he would have let it stay down
there if he knew it was awesome
obviously not you have raised the bar in
fact you right now are a legend because
you have raised the bar so [__] high
that you've taught every Chef in the
world how not to cook congratulations
feel
horrible
not seeing that fridge was beyond belief
I could not believe it I had no idea I
just am speechless
still you and me for a second
what was going on I have no idea I don't
go in the walk-in cool I don't manage it
it's not my territory I never even
thought to look in it I am mortified I
am embarrassed by that every right to
defend your husband but I'm not here to
sugarcoat I understand you're right
but I create some form of understanding
you cannot perform like that
you must see the problem surely I surely
do
what's happened to him I don't know
what's happened to him if I knew I could
help him work through it
I can't start
to work with someone that's given up
and right now he's showing me everything
to confirm he's done just that
I'm honestly hand on heart
I think I'm too late
oh geez
it doesn't seem like he cares no He does
care
how do you know
I don't know let me go talk to him
[Music]
what changed one changed him from being
so passionate and energetic into almost
apathetic I love him I love you too I
keep giving up he still love to cook
yeah and show him you want it okay I
know I'm ready and whatever it takes
Chappy's gonna have to come up and meet
me and let's do this together
[Music]
I'm totally mortified and embarrassed I
know so it could show some light show
that you care oh we have done all of
this for nothing
[Music]
I think Chef Ramsay nailed it
and I feel a little let down
he's going through the motion but it's
not feeling the juice
at last night's dinner service Chef
Ramsay was horrified at the bad
practices sit down please this morning
he has gathered the staff to see if he
can uncover any other major issues with
the restaurant you know I came here to
help but my biggest concern right now is
chappie I can't think of a more
dangerous job when you've got an owner
at the helm that doesn't care
they're going to try to talk to him you
even bother to ask him a question and
you're pissing him off the other day
where guests wanted to know it was a
sauce so I asked him he said why the
[__] do you want to know
the kind of standing in the rulers and
the yelling where the customers can hear
that's really really bad
I feel like I always get yelled at a lot
just for everything he shuts you down
snaps at you you're not even allowed to
speak to him until he speaks to you is
he always that condescending absolutely
yes yeah he almost thinking everybody's
after he took the waiters all we care
about is our money and nothing else
everybody's stealing from him
everybody's against him everybody what's
it like dealing with complaints to the
kitchen he usually gets upset yeah
there's nothing wrong with this he'll
taste it he blames everything on us or
the guests give me an example I've had a
coconut cake I was returned to me I
brought it back to chappie he dug it out
of the trash can went back and asked the
guy what was wrong with him from the
trash not good is he different now that
I'm here yeah yeah definitely in what
way he's calmer he's calmer he is I
appreciate everybody's honesty this is
about getting better let me tell you so
as difficult
as it may have been I want you to say
what you've said to me
to the man himself
no matter what happens I've got your
back so be confident be honest
for me to tell chappie what I'm feeling
and what's been going on it's definitely
nerve-wracking there they are I don't
know what he's gonna do I don't know if
he's gonna fire me or how he's going to
accept it Champion is usually a person
who flies off the handle
they have some things to say
Susan Kick It Off please the main thing
chappie is just communicating so we're
on the same page Russ I want to preface
what I have to say
to both of you that I love you both I
love this restaurant so I love the love
please tell me please tell me
it's happy
you're condescending you're rude and
you're abusive
everybody feels I don't think anybody
wants to say it and many times you lose
your temper
and customers can hear you it's hard for
us to work in that condition
it seems to be as though you don't give
a [__] about us as a team out here that
you think we're all against you that we
don't have your back and I want you to
know that we do have your back we would
love to have some support back from you
it's just hard that you don't trust
anyone if you don't trust your staff
then don't [__] hire him
dark when I first started working I was
selling the black and redfish to
everybody but I found out later that it
was swai and ethically as a server
you're asking me to go out and lie to
these people every night
is that true true
you know it's just not right why'd you
do that why'd you swap that fish out and
put this trying to substitute no stop
stop being dishonest with customers and
putting them in the firing line if he
gets called out that's your doing
I just wish you would like listen to us
a little bit
anytime I've brought up an idea or even
try to ask you a question I'm wasting
your time whoa I try to have you back
you're fantastic
I'm directing this more towards
chappie
[Music]
a lot of things have to change
I appreciate everything you say
and you're right on target
traffic
do you find this kind of feedback from
your team helpful
[Music]
I do it does get tough and if I was
negative to you of a personal event I
apologize it wasn't meant to hurt
sometimes I get off the edge too I'm so
blessed that this has happened because
nothing was going to change unless we
went all the way down there put the
light on it looked at it
and said whoa let's fix this
we have slacked off for quite some time
but we'll get back to it
I hope chappie can change I know
sometimes they say you can't teach an
old dog new tricks
but I'm hoping that you can
Chef Ramsay Still Remains unconvinced
that chappie has seen the error of his
ways sir have you heard the Russian
chapies so he has provided champion star
with a fully equipped Stakeout vehicle
so they can monitor his interaction with
the locals hello
how are you
you like Cajun
good have you been there
a couple of times a couple of times tell
me the experience please
[Music]
it's one of the worst dishes you've had
it tastes a little burnt a little bit
burnt wow I'm pretty sure you're
honestly thank you thank you so much
have you heard of chappies the
restaurant I have not you haven't heard
it thank you how are you have you heard
of chapiz I have good good have you been
to Tampines I haven't I didn't feel as
real authentic Cajun we could pray good
oysters and shrimp simple stuff spicy
they had that kind of food there did you
try it
uh I what I tried was not great yeah
like you better create Cajun food on the
Cajun food truck that rolls around
for the price point it's just I think
it's ridiculous I wouldn't mind the paid
30 to 40 for a good entree but it wasn't
good it's it's not authentic Cajun it's
bad food bad atmosphere ready Bad Hat
I'm here to help fix that restaurant
will you bear with me yes I'll give it
one more shot yes I appreciate it okay
thank you bye-bye
thank you
okay were you listening absolutely tough
to watch I agree it is tough to watch I
think you're doing something that they
want and then they don't
so it's a good eye Awakening an epiphany
of what we need to do let's show more
quality absolutely yeah
time to move forward agreed agreed
agreed when you hear people talking on
the street and they don't see you
listening they'll say things and maybe
they wouldn't say in front of you it was
an eye-opener
coming up Jeffy listen to me no all eyes
are on chappie I need you to step up the
plague or go home will he finally lead
his team to a successful service how
long Jeffy almost ready or will his
customers be disappointed again chappie
stop what you're doing stop that's
coming up on Kitchen Nightmares that
would be one pain in my ass gone
after setting chappie hopefully on the
path to change Jeff Ramsay and his team
worked through the night on a major
renovation
[Music]
thank you
for some big changes let's get on with
it please remove your blindfolds
oh
my God welcome to the new chapies that's
nice look at that awesome incredibly
cool
gone are those tacky dating yellow walls
now it's comfortable modern much more
warm and invitable yeah we got rid of a
lot of the chairs and replacing the Pew
so it came back sort of intimate sort of
family feel so much better I love it
take a look at this wall foreign
we have reclaimed wood from a local barn
and then added artistic photos
recognized French Quarter there we got
rid of all the Clutter from Mardi Gras
including Miss Cleo
it's the Ambiance that Nashville wants
yeah and it still plays homage to the
home of Cajun cuisine Sam how do you
feel that
do you have a good day
you like it yes
it's absolutely stunning I love it
everything's So Fresh So Clean so modern
it just oozes New Orleans charm do we
have a happy chappie
it's very very nice
it's not my style but I was just kind of
kind of grin bear it move on thank you
sir
[Applause]
now as big as the decor change was the
menu change is even bigger let's go
through the menu from top to bottom Chef
Ramsay is modernized and reduced the
menu from 100 dishes to 22. first of all
that is the only page
yes let's start off with the top shrimp
and grits done with Creole seasoning
onions and tomato delicious
next to that Blackened Redfish served
with Citronelle and a herb salad and
what do we do when we run out of redfish
chappie it's 86 86. let's try it so
don't even ask for it Fried Chicken
served with apple butter delicious apple
butter
absolutely delicious
chappie you've gone quiet I'm thinking
how we're going to do it
I'll tell you something your Cooks have
been here since early this morning they
have been under the guidance of a great
chef that I brought here Chris Fox Chris
good morning
this young man has been cooking for over
15 years he has the most amazing wealth
of experience what
what I paid for Chris to be here to
really Implement these standards after I
have gone I think Chef Chris is such a
blessing chappie's going to get a chance
to work side by side with this gentleman
so there are no excuses okay
there's something else I need to bring
in uniforms
oh my God the uniforms are great now
it's casual and this whole new image
it's gonna be fantastic it feels
appropriate no white shirt no bow tie no
black pants and talking about pants
one more thing
when you're looking the parts
there goes the party hat and the clown
pants I love it uh listen to what I'd
like you all to do now is to dig in and
taste the food oh my gosh that pork chop
is ridiculous oh my God there is no
comparison between Chappy's old food and
Chubby's the recipes are there the
flavor is there but I'm not totally
convinced that he's happy I think he's
still like got all these thoughts like
pondering and wondering so uh we'll see
how that goes hmm
[Music]
okay that side down push nice and flat
after more training on the new menu with
Chef Ramsay and Chef Chris did a really
supercharged right you'll have beautiful
marks look great got it all the tools
are there for chappie to have a
successful relaunch I think I'm gonna do
the grilled Angus steak okay yeah I
actually want to try the uh the crab
cake all right thanks guys
fire 114. two pork chops two Angus
steaks one medium one mid rare
uh Jeffy call back please or Chopper
serious pleasure
I got you chuffy Chris is Expediting
he's going to tell you what to do just
do it how long on these steaks how long
Chaffee almost ready [__] now Chris
like what does almost mean like five
seconds two seconds three seconds one
second
give me a time please
I'm not asking for the fastest kitchen I
just want a little bit of call back yes
chef no Chef uh live in Us in here a
little bit
because you're medium rare I needed two
pork chops where's the pork chop please
I need those pork chops desperately
chappie if you get in the game a little
bit please they're in the oven they
should have been put in the oven a while
ago though yeah they've been in there's
got to be quicker than that [__] me we
haven't said anything yet it's almost
like we've gone to sleep
as chappie struggles with the new menu
the question is is it because it's new
or is it because he's not thrilled about
serving it I have such a hard time
serving a plate like that whatever the
case may be customers are starting to
get impatient
let's go I need those chops we already
look like jerks wow I need 114. I need
129. I'm also ready for 110. oh my God
if Kathy would listen it would be so
much better choppy Jeffy listen to me
something not very good at doing stop
what you're doing stop
I need 114. I need 129. it's relaunch
night and chappie is not responding to
Chef Chris if I haven't said anything
yet
and Chef Ramsay knows he has to do
something to save the service Jeffy
listen to me something not very good at
doing
come here a minute
this is it now I understand no no but if
you understand I need to hear you I do I
cannot deliver any more I need you to
step up to the plague and run your
restaurant got it either do it or go
home got it let's go let's go
he's not good at listening that one fire
110 pork chops shrimp and grits
chappie don't ignore that ticket there
110.
I need those pork chops yummy butterfly
do not butterfly them how long are they
it's gonna be a couple minutes at least
three minutes four minutes
butterflied it also you
you cannot do that I don't want the more
butterfly like that those days have gone
I'm not coming this far now to start
stopping food out uh Chris come around
now please I don't want him pasteurizing
the full chop just to get out there yes
sir I'm gonna get in the oven okay yeah
he's got two anger steak what made you
want one medium 127 128 127 126. thank
you make sure you're calling back
I wish that chubby would be a little bit
more open-minded to accept some of the
changes I really hope he does
with Chef Chris switching from expediter
to head chef
please food is now making its way out to
the dining room here's your food Bon
Appetit how hungry are you thank
goodness we love you all the flavors
compliment each other it's very good the
mac and cheese is amazing
everybody's been happy with the food
thank God all your dinners are out I got
the last table
it's just wonderful we have a great new
menu that's fresh and delivered
beautifully we just have to stick with
it believe in it and do everything we
couldn't make it happen
how are you I'm okay everybody seemed to
love everything but not just have a hard
time with it I still think my food's
great
and that would be one pain in my ass
gone
okay
chappie after Chris's time is done here
you need to find and invest in a chef
like Chris there should be someone
qualified in that kitchen on a daily
basis
absolutely because it's worth it the
only thing that's going to keep this
place on the map it's the food will do
stop you must make me a very serious
promise you must not let chappie go
backwards
I promise that good I'm only telling you
this for your own good because you're
one stubborn man
good luck to you both
yeah thank you it was my prayer
I don't know how you did it thank you so
much
come here
good luck to you both thank you take
care thank you so much good night
I've got one word to describe my time
here at chapiz and that is challenging
mainly because Chaffee LED his
restaurant slide in so many ways but we
made a major turnaround and he even
agreed to get rid of these ridiculous
chef's hat my only hope now is that he's
got rid of all those bad habits because
if he hasn't this restaurant has no
chance
wow
not long after Chef Ramsay left in spite
of positive feedback about the changes
chappie went back to his old ways you
didn't do what I have to I should have
come behind you and babysat you you're
right the majority of his original
dishes are back black and pork chop
black and swordfish on the Fly and so
was the uncertainty of the future of
this Nashville restaurant